こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
はいというわけで今回はなんとですね
無料でここのドリンクが１本手に入るという情報をきいたので
今回それを実際にやっていこうと思う
（;≧皿≦）。゜°。ううううぅぅぅ
あ、あれ、こ、声がでない、声がでないよ
あ、あれこの声は？
親分？　(HIKAKIN)
声が親分になってる～～～！！
まあ、いいか、このままやっていこう!!☆
オレが、YouTubeのゴッド☆
はじめしゃちょー（hajime)だ。
今日も、女性ファンは、メロメロになってることだろう☆
それでは、紹介していこう。！
今日、ご紹介するのは、こちら！
見ての、通り、コカ・コーラの自販機だな～
分かってるかい？お前ら！×３
チ～ん
で　今日は
この自販機と　連動して使える
という　便利なアプリのご紹介です
簡単に説明すると
このアプリ
いいかぁ
それではアプリのほうを見せていくぞぉ
数百万人のみんなぁ
よぉ～し
こちらだ！
これがスタンプ
で　ポチッと押すと
はい　今ね　これ
ゼロなんですよ
ひとつもスタンプがたまっていない
そう　ただ　こっから15本買ってスタンプをためちゃうぜぇ～
ふふっw（HIKAKIN)
それじゃあ買っていこう！
で　接続方法はめちゃめちゃ簡単
え～　スマホの位置情報　そしてBluetoothをONにしてここに近づけるだけだ
Coke ONを起動してね
すると
あ！！　きたっ！！　きたっ！！
きたっ！！　ほら　きたでしょ～！　ほら～！
この青い画面で接続完了だ～
で　この状態で買う！
で　もちろん買うのはコカ・コーラだな～
うへっｗ　えっｗ
それじゃあ買っていくぞ！
ON！
ガタッ（落ちる音）
おっけー！　これでこれで画面を見ると
はい！　スタンプが１　たまりました～
この調子で15本
いっちゃうぜ！！
カメラ止めてください親分（HIKAKIN)
飲まない…ｗ（はじめしゃちょー)　ぬふふふｗ（HIKAKIN)
ポチィ
ふふふｗ（HIKAKIN)
プルルルルルル…プーン！！
ブンブン　レディース　エン　ジェントルメン
ここいらで始めるぜ！　ビートボクサー はじめーん！！
ポテュクテュポッ！テュクテュ！ポッ！！ポテュクテュポッ！！…Coke ON!
バチィ！　ふふふｗ（HIKAKIN)
たまったぜ～～　ふはははは！
うひゃはははは！！
これでえ～　15のスタンプがたまった訳なんだが
最後にここで
カッコつけてスワイプすると好きなジュースがもらえるぜぃ
それじゃあドリンクを選んでいこう～
このドリンクチケットってとこで選ぶんだ
で　接続した状態でドリンクチケットを押す！
ポォチ
ほら！！　見てこれ！　すごいでしょう！
へっへっへ！　うへへっへ！！
それじゃあスワイプするぞぉ～！
15本の努力がここで…
はぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ～！！！！！！！　ｗふぁふうｒｊ！
ガタン（落ちる音）
来たようだね！
みろ～
はっははははは！
みんなも15本せっかくならスタンプためて
ただでもらってくれよな
はい　というわけで無事ですね
なんとか
無料でゲットすることができました
できました　できました　よかったです
今ですね　デザインがちょっと変わりまして
はい
こちらラベルがなんと　今
リボンになるらしいです
そう　よく見るとメタリックなんだよね
そうですよ　カッコいいんですよね
そう　リボンっぽいの　こう　なんか色が　ほら
雪の感じも出てるしね
すごい簡単にできるんですよ
ちょっとやってみますね
まず普通にですね
ここ　１番ラベルをはがすってゆうとこではがして
ふん！
こう　グルッと取って
ここですね
テープを引き出すって場所があるので
ここを引っ張ります
これがね　おもしろいんだ
これすごいですよね　いきますよ
よいしょっとぉ～
はい！　リボンの完成です
おぉ～！　リボン！！
おぉ～！すげ～！
で　ここクルルルルってやって
くっつくんだよね　これね　よいしょ
おー！　くっつく
できたー！
すげー！かわいい！
すごいでしょ！
くぅ！！
というわけで　Coke ON　とてもおすすめです
えーっと　普通にドリンク１５本買うだけで１本　本当にタダでもらえるので
是非みなさんもやってみてください！！
動画の説明欄のほうにCoke ONのリンクがあるので是非そちらからダウンロードして使ってみてください！
おねがいします！
で　今回ですね
今回ですね　親分に乗り移られたという設定で声がちょっと変わってたと思うんですけども
あれの親分の声が僕バージョンの動画もあるので　そちらも是非下から見てみてください！
是非ご覧ください！
で　どっちが似ていたかよかったら是非コメントで書いてください！
お願いしやす！
じゃんけんタ～イム！！
それではいきますよ！！
最初はブンブン
じゃんけんぽん！！
チ～ん
あっはははっは！！！
バァ～イ
どうぞ　お疲れ様でした　ふふふふｗ
他まわろうか　全部配ります！